One of the big issues that I see with artificial intelligence is that we're building these powerful AI systems that are shaping the world. And they're influencing the future for everyone who lives in the world, but also everyone who will live in the future. But they're being created by a tiny minority of the world population. So very small number of people in a room building these AI systems. And one of the problems that emerges when with that kind of relationship is that sometimes the benefits and the harms of the AI systems that we're building are unevenly distributed. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology. I'm Kim Mills. We're doing something a little bit different this week. In early January, the American Psychological Association joined the Consumer Technology Association at CES, the world's largest.
我认为人工智能存在的一个大问题是，我们正在构建这些塑造世界的强大人工智能系统。它们正在影响世界上每个人的未来，也包括未来生活在世上所有人的未来。但它们却是由世界人口中的极少数人创造的。也就是说，只有极少数人在房间里构建这些人工智能系统。而这种关系所带来的问题之一，就是我们构建的人工智能系统的益处和危害有时分配不均。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》。我是金·米尔斯。本周我们将做一些略有不同的内容。今年1月初，美国心理学协会在消费电子展（CES）上联合消费技术协会，这是全球最大的
technology trade show for a series of discussions about how technology is shaping human behavior and about how psychological science can help the development of more ethical and effective technology amid the robots gaming systems smart tech and AI powered everything on display at CES we talked about some of the field's biggest questions how can we harness the power of artificial intelligence ethically can digital health interventions help solve the the mental health crisis? How should companies approach online privacy? And can video games promote mental health? After the discussion on AI, we caught up with panelists Nathaniel Fast, director of the Neely Center for Ethical Leadership and Decision Making at the USC Marshall School of Business.
科技贸易展，举办了一系列讨论，探讨技术如何塑造人类行为，以及心理学科学如何帮助开发更具道德和更高效的技术。在CES展示的机器人、游戏系统、智能技术和人工智能驱动的一切事物之中，我们探讨了该领域一些最大的问题：我们如何合乎道德地利用人工智能的力量？数字健康干预措施能否帮助解决心理健康危机？企业应如何处理在线隐私？视频游戏能否促进心理健康？在关于人工智能的讨论结束后，我们采访了小组讨论嘉宾内撒尼尔·法斯特，他是南加州大学马歇尔商学院尼利道德领导力和决策中心的主任。
Dr. Fast is an expert on technology adoption and studies how power and status influence people's decision-making, how it interacts with human behavior, and how AI will shape our future. We talked about why people might make less ethical decisions when they're acting through AI agents, whether most of us trust AI, and why it's important to make sure that the potential benefits of AI flow to everyone and not just the most privileged. Here's our discussion. If you want to hear more from Dr. Fast and the other psychologists who spoke at CES, you can find all the talks at cES.apa.org. So Dr. Frest, I want to say thanks for joining us here at CES.
法斯特博士是技术采纳方面的专家，研究权力和地位如何影响人们的决策、它如何与人类行为相互作用，以及人工智能将如何塑造我们的未来。我们探讨了为什么人们在通过人工智能代理行事时可能会做出不太符合道德的决策，我们大多数人是否信任人工智能，以及为什么确保人工智能的潜在益处惠及所有人、而不仅仅是最具特权的人群至关重要。以下是我们的讨论。如果您想收听更多来自法斯特博士以及在CES上发言的其他心理学家的内容，您可以在 cES.apa.org 上找到所有演讲。法斯特博士，我想感谢您今天加入我们在CES的节目。
We're in Las Vegas at the most incredible technology show in the world. And you were part of a panel presentation this morning on artificial intelligence and ethics. And I just want to ask you a few questions coming from that and from the work that you do. So I'm wondering, as we talk about AI technologies, they're being developed, an amazingly fast pace right now. And there are doom and gloom predictions out there about what AI is going to do to our lives, but there are also people who are saying
我们在拉斯维加斯，这里是世界上最不可思议的技术展。您今天上午参加了一个关于人工智能与伦理的小组讨论。我只想根据这些讨论以及您的工作向您提出几个问题。我想知道，当我们谈论人工智能技术时，它们目前正以惊人的速度发展。关于人工智能将对我们的生活产生什么影响，有各种末日论的预测，但也有人说
that our lives will be changed for the better. Where do you fall on that spectrum? Thanks. It's great to be here. You know, I'll first preface it by saying I'm pretty excited about AI and where technology is going in today's world. It's a very exciting time to be alive. but I definitely get both sides.
我们的生活将会变得更好。在这个光谱中，您倾向于哪一边？谢谢。很高兴来到这里。你知道，我首先要说的是，我对人工智能以及今天世界技术的发展感到非常兴奋。这是一个非常令人兴奋的生存时代。但我绝对理解双方的观点。
I understand the people who are very concerned, and I share a lot of the concerns that, I guess those that you might say are in the Dumer camp have. I also share some of the excitement that some who might be techno-optimists have. I think it's pretty naive to think that it's going to be one way or the other. I mean, I don't think we've ever developed a powerful technology or tool that only had positive uses or negative harms for society. And so for me, I think, you know, I see myself as kind of a measured optimist.
我理解那些非常担忧的人，并且我也赞同那些你可能会说是末日论阵营的人所持的许多担忧。我也赞同一些技术乐观主义者所怀有的兴奋。我认为认为非此即彼是相当天真的。我的意思是，我认为我们从未开发过只有积极用途或对社会只有负面危害的强大技术或工具。所以对我来说，你知道，我觉得自己算是一个有分寸的乐观主义者。
I think I'm optimistic because I think as psychologists, we know that we often get what we are looking for, the self-fulfilling prophecy. And so I think it really makes sense for us to be optimistic about what we can achieve as humans in response to these new technologies. But I'm very measured about it because I think that there's. there's a lot of tremendous harms and downsides of these technologies if we don't, if we don't kind of deploy them and adopt them and use and govern them effectively. In your research, you look at how interacting with AI may change human behavior and the
我认为我很乐观，因为作为心理学家，我们知道我们经常会得到我们所寻找的东西，也就是自我实现的预言。因此，我认为对于我们作为人类能够通过应对这些新技术取得的成就保持乐观是非常有意义的。但我对此非常谨慎，因为我认为这些技术存在着。如果我们不以有效的方式部署、采纳、使用和治理它们，这些技术将会带来巨大的危害和负面影响。在您的研究中，您探讨了与人工智能互动如何改变人类行为以及
way we relate to each other. For example, in one study, you looked at how using an AI assistant might actually make people behave less ethically. And that's what you were talking about this morning. of AI. Can you talk about that study, what you did and what did you find? Well, I mean, we're actually still in the early phases of this and we described this. I described this in a paper with John Gratch and John is in his team are the ones who did that particular study. But what we're finding overall is that we can often hide behind the AI that we're using to kind of mediate our
我们彼此交往的方式。例如，在一项研究中，您探讨了使用人工智能助手实际上可能会如何导致人们做出不太符合道德的行为。这就是您今天早上谈到的内容。人工智能。您能谈谈那项研究吗？你们做了什么，又发现了什么？嗯，我的意思是，我们实际上仍处于这一领域的早期阶段，我们在论文中对此进行了描述。我和约翰·格拉奇在一篇论文中描述了这一点，约翰和他的团队正是进行那项特定研究所的人。但我们总体发现的是，我们经常可以躲在我们用来调解我们
relationships. And so when we are face-to-face, as we are now, you know, there's a greater sense of kind of evolutionary pressure that I think is a positive one to kind of treat each other fairly and so on and not manipulate each other or do harm. But when our interactions are mediated by an AI assistant or an AI model that's negotiating on our behalf, then we can kind of hide behind that. And you can also think about it in terms of algorithms, like if you're hailing a ride from Lyft or Uber and the price looks a little low, you know, it's a little easier to just kind of let that algorithm do its thing. And it's a little bit harder for us to kind of like step in and do something about it. And so I think what we were trying to say in that article was just that
关系的AI背后。因此，当我们像现在这样面对面时，你知道，有一种更大程度的进化压力，我认为这是一种积极的压力，促使我们彼此公平对待等等，不互相操纵或造成伤害。但当我们的互动由AI助手或代表我们进行谈判的AI模型进行调解时，我们就可以某种程度上躲在它后面。你也可以从算法的角度来思考这个问题，比如如果你用Lyft或Uber叫车，价格看起来有点低，你知道，顺其自然地让算法发挥作用会更容易一些。而我们要想介入并采取点行动就会稍微困难一些。所以我想我们在那篇文章中试图表达的只是
there's some potential for kind of moving in an unethical direction maybe more so than we would naturally, the more we adopt AI. Another study that I have with Roshney, Ravindran, and Peter Carnival, we looked at managers. And when managers, we put managers in situations where they had to engage in kind of socially unacceptable behaviors like micromanagement and things like that, they much preferred to use virtual, you know, to manage virtually rather than in person when they were doing those types of things. And so I think that also speaks to the psychology that we kind of hide behind these
随着我们越来越多地采用人工智能，朝着不道德方向发展的可能性可能会比我们自然状态下更大。我和罗什尼·拉维兰恩以及彼得·卡尼瓦尔合作的另一项研究中，我们研究了管理者。当我们将管理者置于必须从事微观管理等社会不可接受的行为的情境中时，在做这些类型的事情时，他们明显更喜欢进行虚拟管理，而不是面对面管理。因此，我认为这也反映了一种心理，即在某些情况下我们某种程度上躲在这些
technologies in some cases. Speaking of hiding behind technologies, you studied how much people trust AI, for instance, whether they'd rather be monitored at work, if they're going to be monitored at work, by a human or an AI system. What have you found? Well, it's interesting. So I found kind of opposite results, but they actually make a lot of sense. So across a couple of different projects. So in one project with Rajne again, we actually found that people are more willing to be tracked when the tracking is done by technology only. So if, people are at work and they're going to be tracked by their computer or a smart watch or something
技术背后。说到躲在技术背后，您研究了人们对人工智能的信任程度，例如，如果在工作中受到监控，他们是更愿意由人类监控还是由人工智能系统监控。您发现了什么？嗯，这很有趣。所以，我发现了某种程度上相反的结果，但它们实际上非常合乎情理。跨越了几个不同的项目。因此，在与拉什尼再次合作的一个项目中，我们实际上发现，当追踪完全由技术完成时，人们更愿意被追踪。如果人们在工作，并且将由他们的计算机、智能手表或类似的东西进行追踪
like that. It's kind of monitoring their performance and things like that. They're much more willing to say yes to those situations than when those same tools are being used to track them, but there's a human who's doing analyzing the data and looking at the data and all of that kind of stuff. And we found that even when we told them what the data were going to be used for and so on, there's something psychological that we've kind of evolved to feel kind of, What we argued and found in our paper was that people feel kind of less autonomy when they're being watched by another person. That creates kind of a social pressure to perform and to not be judged negatively, whereas the technology doesn't judge us. It just kind of measures our performance.
它在监控他们的表现之类的事情。与由人类分析数据、查看数据以及所有这些类似事情的相同工具相比，他们更愿意对这些情况说“是”。我们发现，即使我们告诉他们这些数据将用于什么用途等等，我们的心理已经进化到会感受到某种，我们在论文中论述并发现的是，当被另一个人监视时，人们会觉得自主性有所降低。这会产生一种表现和不被负面评判的社交压力，而技术不会评判我们。它只是衡量我们的表现。
And so people tend to have a greater preference for that. But in another paper with David Newman and Derek Harmon, we actually found that, you know, once we have all these data that we're collecting, in the organizational context, we can actually use them to make decisions like HR decisions, hiring and firing and promotions and things like that, and perhaps remove some of this human bias that enters into these decisions. And it's one of the biggest things that employees are, you know, complain about is human bias in these decisions. But what we found is that actually people in that case prefer humans to make the decisions. And so we would give them a whole set of different, you know, HR-related decisions that were made. And when we told them those same
因此，人们往往更倾向于这种方式。但在与大卫·纽曼和德里克·卡门合作的另一篇论文中，我们实际上发现，一旦我们收集了所有这些数据，在组织背景下，我们实际上可以利用它们来做出决策，比如人力资源决策、招聘、解雇和晋升之类的事情，或许还能消除进入这些决策中的一些人类偏见。这是员工抱怨最多的事情之一，即这些决策中的人类偏见。但我们发现，实际上在这种情况下，人们更倾向于由人类来做出决策。因此，我们会给他们提供一系列不同的、你知道的、由人工做出的与人力资源相关的决策。而当我们告诉他们这些相同的
decisions were made by an algorithm and AI, they viewed them as less fair than when they were made by humans. And so we have this kind of juxtaposition where we're giving our data, you know, we're more willing to be tracked and provide our data, which might be problematic for privacy. Once we have that data, we could actually use it to make good decisions. But in those cases, And that's when we want to step in and say we don't trust it. So it's kind of interesting. But with some of these AI, with some of these HR applications of AI, because AI is basically scraping what's out there in the world and coming together
决策是由算法和人工智能做出的时，他们认为这些决策比由人类做出时更不公平。因此，我们面临这样一种并列情况：我们交出数据，你知道，我们更愿意被追踪并提供数据，这可能会对隐私造成问题。一旦我们有了这些数据，我们实际上可以用它来做出好的决策。但在这些情况下，这正是我们想要介入并表示我们不信任它的时候。所以这有点有趣。但对于人工智能的一些人力资源应用来说，由于人工智能基本上是在抓取世界上现有的内容并汇集在一起
and then using the data to basically interpret and, I mean, it becomes a tool for us. What I'm trying to get at is that AI can be as biased as we are, the people who create the initial data that goes into the AI. And so we've seen in some HR instances where AI makes the same bias decisions that the human beings make. How can we counteract that? So Amazon famously tried to create a hiring algorithm and they had to scrap it at the end. They tried to overcome the bias. It kept hiring men and suggesting that they hire men and not women.
然后利用这些数据来进行基本解释，我的意思是，它成了我们的工具。我想表达的是，人工智能可能和我们一样带有偏见，也就是那些创建输入到人工智能中的初始数据的创建者。因此，我们已经在一些人力资源实例中看到，人工智能做出了与人类相同的偏见决策。我们如何对此进行反制？亚马逊曾大肆尝试创建一个招聘算法，但最终不得不废弃它。他们试图克服这种偏见。它不断地招募男性，并建议招募男性而不是女性。
And so they took names out. They tried to strip everything out from their resumes. But the AI is very good at assessing and knowing what's, you know, whether you played women's sports in college or whether you use even certain adjectives to describe your performance that men and women differed on that. And so they had to scrap that. So in some cases, I think we actually just need to not rely on AI when we can't remove that from the system. In other cases, Sindel Mullenathan and his team of researchers have this great stuff. where they found that there was racism embedded in a decision-making algorithm that was used by hospital in a medical context. And they actually did an audit of the algorithm and they were able to find that it was making decisions that were based on monetary preferences that ended up being racist decisions.
因此，他们去掉了名字。他们试图从简历中剥离所有东西。但人工智能非常擅长评估和了解，你知道的，你是否在大学里参加过女子体育运动，或者你是否使用了某些形容词来描述你的表现，而男性和女性在这些词上有差异。因此他们不得不废弃它。所以在某些情况下，我认为当无法从系统中消除这些偏见时，我们实际上只需要不依赖人工智能。在其他情况下，辛德尔·穆拉纳坦和他的研究团队有一些很棒的成果。他们发现，医院在医疗背景下使用的决策算法中嵌入了种族主义。他们实际上对该算法进行了审计，并能够发现它做出了基于金钱偏好的决策，而这些决策最终变成了种族主义决策。
And they were able to go in and fix those. And as Sindel talks about, you know, once you fix an algorithm, a decision-making algorithm, it doesn't make them a decision-making algorithm. it doesn't make that mistake anymore, but you can kind of tell people that they're making biased decisions and they continue to make them, you know, year after year. And so there is, you know, it's not as easy as just saying let's throw it out all together or let's always use it. I think we have to be really smart about how we're doing this. You know, your panel this morning was about ethics and AI. And I got to thinking about a story I had read about somebody who really wanted to be on the podcast that Esther Perel does, the psychologist who talks about relationships
他们能够介入并修复这些问题。正如辛德尔所说，你知道，一旦你修复了一个算法，一个决策算法，它就不会再犯那个错误了，但你可以告诉人们他们在做有偏见的决策，而他们年复一年地继续这样做。所以这里有，你知道，这并不像说“让我们完全抛弃它”或“让我们一直使用它”那么容易。我认为我们在如何做到这一点上必须非常聪明。你知道，你今天早上的小组讨论是关于伦理和人工智能的。我想到了我读到的一个故事，关于一个非常想上埃丝特·佩瑞尔的播客的人，埃丝特·佩瑞尔是一位谈论关系并实际上在她的播客中与人们一起工作的心理学家
and works with people actually on her podcast. And because he couldn't quite get on the show, he created an AI Esther Perel. And I think we're seeing more of these kinds of things happening. I read about an AI Marty Seligman and other psychologists because they have a big body of work out there that can be synthesized. Is that an ethical thing to do?
因为他无法上这个节目，他创建了一个AI版的埃丝特·佩瑞尔。我想我们正在看到越来越多这类事情发生。我读到了关于AI版的马丁·塞利格曼和其他心理学家的报道，因为他们拥有可以被综合的大量著作。这样做合乎伦理吗？
And, you know, if somebody wanted to make an AI of you, how would you feel about that? Yeah, well, I definitely would feel concerned and I'm you know, that's one of the things that I'm concerned about a lot of people are concerned about especially as we head into the election. You know, with 20 to 30 seconds of a voice, a person's voice, you can actually create a deep fake that sounds just like that person. We can do that with videos now too. It's this is this is new territory for us. We have to figure, you know, figure these things out. I certainly can't say that I'm comfortable. with that idea, I think we will find our way as a society and try to figure out how to handle those situations. But it's probably going to be messy. And this upcoming election is actually going to be quite messy as well. You have also talked about the need to democratize AI to make sure that the benefits get to everyone in all parts of the world. What does that mean? What do you mean when you say democratize AI?
而且，你知道，如果有人想做一个关于你的AI，你会有什么感觉？是的，嗯，我肯定会感到担忧，而且你知道，这也是我担心的事情之一，很多人都很担心，特别是当我们走向大选时。你知道，只需20到30秒的声音，一个人的声音，你就可以创建一个听起来和那个人一模一样的深度伪造（deepfake）。我们现在也可以用视频做到这一点。这是这是我们的新领域。我们必须弄清楚，你知道，弄清楚这些事情。我当然不能说我对
people are talking about democratizing AI and they mean different things. And so I think that is exactly where we should start with that question. And the reason why it's a big priority for me is that we live in a world where right now we're developing powerful AI systems. And these AI systems are affecting the entire world. And not only there are they affecting the entire world, but also all future humans who are lucky enough to walk the face of the earth are going to be affected by these systems too. And they're made by such a tiny minority of the existing population in the world today. So that's a problem in my perspective. I've studied power for most of my career.
这种想法感到放心，我认为我们会作为社会找到自己的路，并试图弄清楚如何处理这些情况。但这可能会是一团糟。即将到来的大选实际上也会相当混乱。你还谈到了普及人工智能的必要性，以确保其益处惠及全球各个角落的每一个人。这到底是什么意思？你说的“普及人工智能”是什么意思？
And that's a power imbalance if you've ever seen one. And so we do need to democratize AI, meaning we need better. We need to infuse the AI systems that we're building with. more input from around the world. And there are different things you can democratize. And I want to make this point here because I think big tech often talks about democratizing AI. And I don't really like the way that they're talking about it.
人们在谈论普及人工智能时，他们的意思并不完全相同。因此，我认为这正是我们应该从这个问题开始的地方。它对我来说是一个高度优先事项的原因是，我们生活在一个正在开发强大人工智能系统的世界里。而这些人工智能系统正在影响着整个世界。不仅如此，它们正在影响着整个世界，而且所有有幸来到这个世上的未来人类也将受到这些系统的影响。而它们却是由当今世界现有总人口中的极少数人制造的。从我的角度来看，这是一个问题。我的整个职业生涯都在研究权力。
They mean creating cheap products that lots of people can use. And there's nothing inherently wrong with products that a lot of people can use. But in the case of something like social media, you know, making sure that it's like a free product that everybody gets to use and in many ways humans are kind of the product there. I don't know that democratizing access to that is is really a positive force for good that democratizing implies. And so when I talk about democratizing AI, I'm really talking about democratizing the design of the systems, democratizing the use of the systems and democratizing the governance of the systems and really finding ways for more people's voices to be infused into each of those
如果你见过权力失衡的话，这就是了。因此，我们确实需要普及人工智能，这意味着我们需要更好的。我们需要在我们正在构建的人工智能系统中注入。更多来自世界各地的输入。你可以普及不同的东西。我想在这里强调这一点，因为大型科技公司经常谈论普及人工智能。但我其实并不喜欢他们谈论它的方式。
those three areas. A lot of educators worry that artificial intelligence is going to change teaching and learning for the worst by letting a lot of students offload their writing and other work to AI chatbots. You're a professor, as well as a researcher. Is this something you worry about? How do you approach it in your classroom? Yeah, no, I mean, I'm not worried about it. Maybe I should be. But I'm not worried about it because as long as we change how we teach, I think we're going to be okay, and I actually believe we need to change how we teach. I think we've needed to change how we teach for a long, long time.
他们的意思是创造许多人都可以使用的廉价产品。许多人可以使用的产品本身并没有什么内在的错误。但在像社交媒体这样的情况下，你知道，确保它是一个每个人都可以使用的免费产品，并且在许多方面人类在某种程度上成为了那里的产品。我不知道普及对这种产品的访问是否真的是一种能够带来积极影响的力量，正如“普及”所暗示的那样。因此，当我谈论普及人工智能时，我实际上是在谈论普及系统的设计、普及系统的使用以及普及系统的治理，并真正寻找方法将更多人的声音融入到每一个
And so when we make our classrooms more experiential, when we make them more kind of exploratory, team-based, things like that, I think people learn a lot more through working on projects together. And so I think AI actually lends itself really well for students to kind of explore. explore new tools and explore new ways of using AI. But it does require that we change and it requires that we both find good ways of using AI and also, you know, especially when we're trying to teach writing, yeah, we're going to probably have to have people work on that in the classroom and flip the classroom.
这三个领域中。许多教育工作者担心，人工智能将允许许多学生将他们的写作和其他工作卸载给人工智能聊天机器人，从而彻底改变教学。你既是一名教授，也是一名研究员。这是你担心的事情吗？你在课堂上是如何处理这个问题的？是的，不，我的意思是，我并不担心。也许我应该担心。但我并不担心，因为只要我们改变教学方式，我认为我们就会没事的，而且我实际上相信我们需要改变教学方式。我认为我们早就应该改变教学方式了。
If they do it at home, they're going to use chat GPT in many cases. And so, you know, but I think we can handle this. I think we can find good ways to continue to educate people. Despite these concerns, AI does have the potential to transform our lives in beneficial ways as well. What are some of your biggest hopes for AI at this point? There's a lot of benefits, and another reason why it's important to kind of democratize the use of AI. And I think this comes from kind of educating and getting the word out to populations that might not otherwise get the word out is because there are benefits of AI. So like I was just recently in Kenya and was touring the Cabrera slum.
因此，当我们让课堂更具体验性，当我们让它们更具探索性、团队合作性等时，我认为人们通过一起从事项目会学到更多东西。因此，我认为人工智能实际上非常适合学生去探索。探索新工具并探索使用人工智能的新方法。但这确实需要我们做出改变，并且要求我们既要找到使用人工智能的好方法，还要，你知道，特别是在我们试图教授写作时，是的，我们可能不得不让人们在课堂上完成这项工作并翻转课堂。
And my tour guide lives there in Cabrara. And I asked him if he had ever heard of Chad GPT. And, you know, I was across the world. I thought I would take advantage of the opportunity to ask someone. And it turns out he had, and he surprised me. He had heard of ChatGPT. He had heard about it from somebody from the UK who was on a tour. And he actually uses ChatGPT to increase bookings.
如果他们在家里做，在很多情况下他们会使用ChatGPT。因此，你知道，但我认为我们可以处理好这件事。我认为我们可以找到继续教育人们的好方法。尽管存在这些担忧，人工智能确实也有以有益方式改变我们生活的潜力。在这一点上，你对人工智能的最大期望是什么？有很多好处，这也是为什么普及人工智能的使用很重要的另一个原因。我认为这来自于教育并向可能无法得知消息的人群传播消息，因为人工智能是有好处的。就像我最近去了肯尼亚，参观了基贝拉贫民窟。
And he takes its advice about like, how to take pictures, how to arrange his website and so on. And so I think that there's a lot of benefits that people around the world who don't have access to great education and who don't have access to personal tutors the way that the wealthy often do, that I'm really excited about people getting access to good tutors. And Khan Academy has created a tool that's pretty exciting as well on that front. I'm also excited about the possibility that AI will bring people together to address it. And maybe I'm a little bit blindly optimistic about this, but I think that there's potential here.
我的导游就住在基贝拉。我问他是否听说过ChatGPT。并且，你知道，我在世界的另一端，我想利用这个机会问问某个人。结果证明他听说过，他让我大吃一惊。他听说过ChatGPT。他是从一个来自英国的旅游团成员那里听说的。他实际上使用ChatGPT来增加预订量。
And so at the Neely Center, at the USC Marshall School of Business that I direct, we have something called the Neely indices where we're tracking user experiences. How are social media platforms affecting users? How are AI models affecting users? how our mixed reality technologies affecting users. One of the things that we found with AI is that both Republicans and Democrats are concerned kind of equally across the board they're both excited and concerned about AI to equal amounts. We haven't politicized this issue yet. Of course we tend to politicize every big issue and so that's a concern but I think it's also an opportunity for us to kind of work together and so that's one thing I'm also hopeful about.
并且他听取了关于如何拍照、如何安排他的网站等的建议。因此，我认为对于世界上那些无法获得优质教育、无法像富人那样拥有私人导师的人来说，有很多好处，我对人们能够获得优质导师感到非常兴奋。可汗学院也创建了一个在这方面相当令人兴奋的工具。我也对人工智能将人们聚集在一起解决问题的可能性感到兴奋。也许我对这一点有点盲目乐观，但我认为这里存在潜力。
One of the things that struck me that you said on the panel here at CES was that we need to slow down the development of AI. Why do you think that? And is it even possible to make business slow down? Well, I mean, that's another good question. And so to clarify, so there's a gap, which is the speed capacity gap that I mentioned. And where we're deploying and developing new AI and new technologies with a greater speed. then we're able to handle. And so we don't have the capacity to kind of make decisions about these new technologies.
因此，在由我担任主任的南加州大学马歇尔商学院尼利中心，我们有一项名为尼利指数的项目，我们在其中追踪用户体验。社交媒体平台如何影响用户？人工智能模型如何影响用户？混合现实技术如何影响用户。我们对人工智能的发现之一是，共和党人和民主党人都同样普遍地对此感到担忧，他们对人工智能的兴奋和担忧程度是相当的。我们还没有将这个问题政治化。当然，我们倾向于将每个重大问题都政治化，所以这是一个担忧，但我认为这也是我们齐心协力合作的一个机会，所以这也是我充满希望的一点。
And we don't know how they're affecting us. And so it's really hard to govern, to set policy, to design technologies more effectively and with greater health benefits when we don't really know how they're affecting us. And so, of course, you can close that gap by either slowing things down or speeding up the capacity. And I'm actually not a big proponent of slowing things down. I do think that one way to slow things down effectively is to hold companies more accountable for the harms that their technologies are creating. When we do that, they're going to slow themselves down by choice because they don't want to put technologies out there too quickly, right? And so I think that kind of slowing down is good, but I don't like the idea of slowing down simply to slow down.
在CES这里的座谈会上，你所说的话中有一点让我印象深刻，那就是我们需要放慢人工智能的发展速度。你为什么这么认为？让企业放慢脚步甚至可能吗？嗯，我的意思是，这是另一个好问题。为了澄清一下，所以存在一个差距，也就是我提到的速度能力差距。我们在以更快的速度部署和开发新人工智能和新技术。超出我们所能处理的范围。因此，我们没有能力对这些新技术做出决策。
And the reason is because we learn from each iteration. And so if you think about something like large language models, each iteration of large language models as we deploy it, we learn a whole bunch of stuff and that gets embedded into the next model. And so if we're trying to learn as much as we possibly can by, say, the year 2030 or 2040, the more iterations that we can have in between now and then, the more we're going to learn and be able to create safer models. The caveat to that is there are times where we're kind of deployed. the technology too quickly and with too much speed that we're not actually able to learn and give adequate feedback in between the iterations. And so that's where we're really working hard to try to elevate the capacity of society. And I think for me anyway, as an academic, one of the best ways that we can improve society's
我们不知道它们是如何影响我们的。因此，当我们真的不知道它们如何影响我们时，很难进行治理、制定政策、更有效地设计技术并带来更大的健康效益。因此，当然，你可以通过放慢速度或提高能力来缩小这一差距。我其实并不是放慢速度的大力倡导者。我确实认为，有效放慢速度的方法之一是让公司为其技术造成的危害承担更多责任。当我们这样做时，他们会由于不想过快推出技术而自愿放慢速度，对吧？因此，我认为这种放慢速度是好的，但我不喜欢为了放慢而放慢的想法。
capacity to handle the speed is actually to collect data more quickly and share it broadly. And so with the Neely indices, for example, we're collecting data about all the different platforms, not just one. We're making it public so the companies feel kind of pressure and also incentives. You know, when they do good things, they also get credit for that. And then we're also sharing that with researchers so that they can actually get research out there quicker. So, you know, I'm more bullish on the idea of like speeding up our capacity than I am on slowing down the tech. But when it comes to punishing a developer that is doing harm, how would that happen? I mean, we have watched Congress try to wrestle with social media, which I think 80% of them don't understand or use.
原因是我们从每一次迭代中学习。因此，如果你考虑像大语言模型这样的东西，随着我们部署大语言模型的每一次迭代，我们会学到一大堆东西，而这些东西会被嵌入到下一个模型中。因此，如果我们试图通过，比如说，2030年或2040年尽可能多地学习，从现在到那时我们能有越多的迭代，我们将学到越多，并能够创建更安全的模型。需要说明的是，有时我们部署。技术太快、速度太快，以至于我们实际上无法在迭代之间学习并给出足够的反馈。因此，这正是我们努力提高社会能力的地方。无论如何，对我来说，作为一名学者，提高社会能力的方法之一
And then we have organizations or regulators like the FTC, but, I mean, they're all so slow on the draw as well. So does the punishment just come from the marketplace? I think the marketplace is the best the best place for punishment to come for the companies with, you know, by not buying products and abandoning products. And you see that with, you know, companies like X or Twitter, you know, and you see some of that market pressure happen as a result of decisions that the companies make. And, and that's another, you know, one of the benefits of the indices that we're trying to work on through the Neely Center is making those data public. And so, for example, you know, Twitter ranked very high on our initial sets of indices for people reporting that there was, you know, content that was bad for the world or bad for them personally, very, and lower on kind of connecting with others or learning new things, whereas like LinkedIn, for example, score very high on or decently high on learning new things and connecting with others, but really low on the harms. And so that's evidence or that's data out there that's relevant
应对速度的能力实际上是更快地收集数据并广泛共享。例如，通过尼利指数，我们正在收集关于所有不同平台的数据，而不仅仅是一个。我们将其公开，以便公司感受到某种压力和激励。你知道，当他们做好事时，他们也会得到认可。然后我们也与研究人员分享这些，以便他们能够更快地发表研究成果。所以，你知道，比起放慢技术的发展，我更看好加快我们的能力建设的想法。但当谈到惩罚一个正在造成危害的开发者时，这会如何发生？我的意思是，我们看着国会试图与社交媒体作斗争，我认为其中80%的人并不理解或使用社交媒体。
to users and they can make decisions about where to spend, their time. I think one of the things that I do want to note, and this is really messy, and a lot of people have a lot of arguments about, like, accelerationists are naive, or maybe the people who are saying, let's take a pause and slow down are naive. I actually think it's a messy debate, which actually is a healthy democracy. That's what that looks like. And so the Future of Life Institute, for example, had the big pause letter, you know, let's pause for six months, things like that. And you could critique those things, but I actually think that they got the policymakers' attention. And I think when you see what policymakers and the kind of the lack of understanding of how social media was
然后我们有像联邦贸易委员会（FTC）这样的组织或监管机构，但是，我的意思是，他们的反应也都非常迟钝。那么惩罚只是来自市场吗？我认为市场是惩罚公司的最佳场所，你知道，通过不买产品和抛弃产品。你可以从像X或Twitter这样的公司身上看到这一点，并且由于公司做出的决定，你可以看到一些市场压力发生。这也是尼利中心试图通过尼利指数做的事情的好处之一，即公开这些数据。因此，举个例子，你知道，在我们的最初几组指数中，Twitter在人们报告存在对世界有害或对自己个人有害的内容方面排名很高，而在与他人联系或学习新事物方面排名较低，而像LinkedIn这样的公司，在学习新事物和与他人联系方面得分很高或相当高，但在危害方面真的很低。因此，这是相关的证据或数据
working back when they were dealing with that, and you compare that to how much they understand about AI, there's a big difference. They are actually a lot more skillful with regard to AI. And they have room to grow. But I think a lot of that is because of the concern that's been generated. So I think everything comes with its pros and cons, but I do want to acknowledge that I think some of those calls had the effect of getting everybody's attention. And I think that's a good thing. Is there enough transparency in AI as it's developing today? No. That's an easy one. We need more transparency. And I think, you know, the companies that are building it, I think we have to have a measure of like kind of mission, almost like
对用户而言，他们可以决定把时间花在哪里。我认为我想指出的事情之一，这真的很混乱，很多人有很多争论，比如加速主义者是天真的，或者说“我们暂停一下，慢下来”的人可能是天真的。我实际上认为这是一场混乱的辩论，这其实是一个健康的民主社会的表现。这正是它的样子。因此，例如，生命未来研究所发表了重大暂停信，你知道，让我们暂停六个月之类的。你可以批评这些事情，但我实际上认为它们引起了决策者的注意。我想当你看到决策者以及他们在处理社交媒体时对其运作方式的缺乏理解时，
missional quality to what they're doing. Like we're building AI. We're doing something that's never been done before. And so part of our mission is to be transparent about what we're, what we're building, how we're building it, what's going into the data, the training data. And, and maybe weighing in on some of the research findings that are out there, there's just a huge stream of research is, is not fun to try to stay on. top of this field, it is like unbelievable. And so I think if companies were more transparent
如果你将这一点与他们对人工智能的理解程度进行比较，就会发现有很大的不同。他们在人工智能方面实际上要熟练得多。他们还有成长空间。但我认为这在很大程度上是因为人们所产生的担忧。所以我认为每件事都有其利弊，但我确实想承认，我认为其中一些呼吁起到了吸引所有人注意力的作用。我认为这是一件好事。在当今人工智能的发展中，透明度足够吗？没有。这是一个很简单的问题。我们需要更多的透明度。并且我认为，你知道，构建它的公司，我认为我们必须对他们正在做的事情有一定的使命感，几乎就像
about what they're doing and how they're doing it as well as like weighing in on some of the research and doing research of their own, I think we're going to be better off the more of that happens. And what are the next big questions for you? What are you working on? I'm, you know, I'm putting a lot of effort this year into efforts to democratize AI in the way that we're talking about, getting more input from around the world. I'll be doing a lot of international travel to talk to people who are in different areas. We're expanding our indices to Poland, to Kenya, to Somalia, to other countries, to collect more data from people who don't typically get their data into the conversations.
使命感一样。就像我们正在构建人工智能。我们正在做一件以前从未做过的事情。因此，我们的部分使命是对我们正在构建的东西、我们如何构建它、什么进入了数据以及训练数据保持透明。并且，也许对现有的某些研究发现发表看法，研究流实在是太巨大了，试图保持对
And then the second thing is really working on purpose-driven technology and trying to shift the paradigm away from kind of maximizing engagement, maximizing profit through engagement. instead, really, you know, tech designers, but also consumers as well as policymakers, thinking about purpose-driven technology, what is the purpose of this particular, you know, what is the purpose of using this large language model or this VR headset? What am I trying to achieve with it? And is it achieving that purpose and, you know, measuring that and what are some of the side, you know, side effects or the harms that come from it?
这个领域的关注可一点也不轻松，简直是难以置信。因此，我认为如果公司对其正在做的事情以及如何做的事情更加透明，并对一些研究发表看法并进行他们自己的研究，随着这种情况的增加，我们的处境会变得更好。对你来说，接下来的重大问题是什么？你在研究什么？我，你知道，今年我投入了大量精力来普及人工智能，采用我们一直在讨论的方式，从世界各地获得更多意见。我将进行大量的国际旅行，与不同地区的人们交谈。我们正在将我们的指数扩展到波兰、肯尼亚、索马里和其他国家，以从那些通常无法将他们的意见纳入对话的人那里收集更多数据。
And we do that with medicine and with new drugs. And I think we need to do that with a lot of these new technologies because they're getting to be quite powerful. And so I'll be focusing on how to shift the paradigm to focus more on purpose-driven tech. And just to illuminate for our listeners what you mean by that, are there some examples of purpose-driven AI technologies right now? Sure. I mean, you can think about the metaverse, all the conversations about the metaverse. And you could think about virtual reality as kind of an opportunity to create. create a virtual space that we push people into or incentivize people into and they spend a bunch
第二件事是真正致力于目标驱动的技术，并试图将范式从最大化参与度、通过参与度最大化利润中转移开。相反，真正地，你知道，技术设计者，还有消费者以及决策者，都在思考目标驱动的技术，这个特定的（你知道的）目的是什么，使用这个大语言模型或这个VR头显的目的是什么？我试图用它实现什么？它是否实现了这个目标，你知道，去衡量这一点，以及它带来的一些副作用或危害是什么？
of time in virtual reality and that's the Metaverse. It's this container and we make money because we collect data from them, you know, lots of data from while they're in there, almost like a glorified social media. It's unclear what the purpose of that is. And so that's like a profit driven or engagement driven model. And that's not actually working. People don't, people are not rushing to Meta's vision of what the Metaverse could be.
我们在医学和新药方面就是这样做的。我认为我们需要对许多这些新技术这样做，因为它们正变得越来越强大。因此，我将专注于如何转变范式，更多地关注目标驱动的技术。为了向我们的听众阐明你的意思，目前有没有一些目标驱动的人工智能技术的例子？当然。我的意思是，你可以考虑元宇宙，所有关于元宇宙的讨论。你可以将虚拟现实视为一种创造机会的方式。
And instead, there's so many, and we heard of many of them today with the APA sessions and others where people are using virtual reality to treat pain or to treat Parkinson's or to improve learning and improve kind of optimism about the world and make a difference in the world and things like that. Those are very purpose-driven experiences that we can create for people.
创造一个我们把人们推入其中或激励人们进入的虚拟空间，他们在虚拟空间里度过大量时间，这就是元宇宙。它是一个容器，我们通过从他们那里收集数据来赚钱，你知道，当他们在里面时收集大量数据，几乎就像一个美化版的社交媒体。目前尚不清楚这背后的目的究竟是什么。所以这是一种利润驱动或参与驱动的模型。而且这实际上并不管用。人们并没有蜂拥至Meta对元宇宙的愿景。
I think the more we do that, I think the better off will be. Well, Dr. Fast, I want to thank you for joining me today. I want to thank you for being here at CES, participating in the panels that APA did today. Well, thank you. It's my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combecingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review.
相反，有那么多，我们在今天的APA会议和其他活动中听到了许多这样的例子，人们正在利用虚拟现实来治疗疼痛、治疗帕金森病、或者改善学习、增强对世界的乐观态度并在世界上产生影响等等。这些都是我们可以为人们创造的非常目标驱动的体验。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayim. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为我们做得越多，我们的处境就会越好。好吧，法斯特博士，我要感谢您今天加入我的节目。我要感谢您来到CES，参加APA今天举办的小组讨论。好的，谢谢您。这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.w.combecingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留下评价。